Many of us have grown reading his tales on
self-destruction, revenge and violence.
Tales of premature burials, of ghastly cats
and ravens, where the line between the living
and the dead is never clear.
But when you look deeper into the life and
works of Edgar Allan Poe a more complex figure
emerges, beyond the traditional image of the
alcoholic, pale, sickly author with an obsession
for death.
Poe’s life was not easy, in many ways: tragic.
And his path crossed the Grim Reaper’s many
times.
But in today’s Biographics we are going
to look at another angle of Poe.
The athletic military man, the rebellious
student, the ruthless reviewer, the father
of detective fiction.
And to satisfy those with morbid fantasies,
we are going to investigate the mystery behind
his death.
Thou Art the Man
Edgar Poe was born on the 19th of January
1809, in Boston, from David and Elizabeth,
two traveling actors.
Edgar’s life had barely started when he
suffered a double trauma.
On the 20th of December 1811 Elizabeth died
of illness, perhaps pneumonia or tuberculosis,
both highly prevalent in the US at that time.
David died within a few days of his wife,
the details are unconfirmed.
According to one account David was performing
in Norfolk, Virginia with his travelling theatre
company, when he also died of an illness.
A different account tells us that by the time
of Elizabeth’s death, the Poe family was
a broken one: David had left the household,
leaving his wife destitute.
Six days after his mother’s death
[Caption: 26th December 1811]
the orphaned Edgar was fostered into the home
of John and Frances Allan of Richmond.
His sister, Rosalie, was taken in by the Mackenzie
family, also of Richmond, while big brother
Henry remained with the grandparents in Baltimore.
John and Frances Allan were a childless couple
and although they never legally adopted Edgar,
they considered him to be their son.
Edgar called them “Pa” and “Ma”.
John was a wealthy merchant, a self-made man
from Scotland.
While Edgar’s relationship with Frances
would always be deeply affectionate, him and
John would frequently clash.
On the 7th of January 1812 Edgar was baptised
as Edgar Allan Poe.
The Allan family with Edgar in tow later moved
to London, where they lived from 1815 to 1820.
During these years the young Edgar learned
grammar, Latin, Greek and – surprise – dancing!
The Allans returned to America in 1820 and
by 1823 Edgar was studying in a school run
by one William Burke.
Not the body snatcher and murderer of Burke
and Hare fame … just a name sake.
But still, nice coincidence.
Like if Stephen King had graduated from Ed
Gein High.
Poe was a very active and athletic teenager,
contradicting the common image of the sickly,
brooding intellectual.
In the summer of 1824 he became famous for
swimming seven miles up the James River, against
a heavy tide.
That’s almost three times the swimming segment
of an Iron Man competition.
[Caption: Take that, King and Lovecraft!]
Apparently schoolmaster Burke followed him
in a boat in case he needed help.
Maybe that’s what kept Edgar going – being
chased by a Scottish serial killer on a boat
is a powerful motivator.
But it wasn’t him, just a name sake.
Later that year, Edgar authored his first
poem, of just two lines:
“Last night, with many cares & toils oppres‘d,
Weary, I laid me on a couch to rest”
Which can be paraphrased as
“I am gonna take a nap on the sofa”
Never Bet the Devil your Head
In February 1826 Edgar enrolled in the University
of Virginia, Charlottesville.
But his studies there were short-lived.
The wealthy John Allan had no intention to
fill Edgar’s pockets with easy money, so
the freshman had to subsidise his expenses
with a side hustle: gambling.
Edgar accumulated $2,000 of gambling debts.
That’s more than $50,000 in today’s money.
John Allan refused to pay, leading to a rift
between the two men, a situation which would
occur again in the future.
That year, Edgar couldn’t really catch a
break.
During Christmas holidays he was looking forward
to reuniting with his childhood sweetheart
and prospective fiancée, But Elmira’s parents
had pressured her into dumping him for a wealthy
and solid businessman Alexander Shelton.
Yeah, we get it, but could he swim seven miles
chased by a Scottish serial killer?
It is understandable if in March 1827 Edgar
decided to leave University and reunite with
older brother Henry in Baltimore.
Still in need of steady income, in May Poe
enlisted in the US Army, under the name Edgar
A. Perry.
Private ‘Perry’ did well in the Army and
rose to the rank of Sergeant-Major of an artillery
regiment in less than two years.
Not only that.
He also found time to write his first book
of poetry, ‘Tamerlane and Other Poems’
published with the pseudonym
“A Bostonian.”
The booklet sold about 50 copies.
If you come across a copy of ‘Tamerlan’
in your great-great-grandparents’ attic,
you could auction it for a nice $172,000.
On the 28th of February 1829, Frances Allan,
‘Ma’, died from a respiratory illness,
just like Edgar’s biological mother.
In the following years Edgar’s behaviour
became erratic and rebellious, probably as
a consequence of Ma’s death.
Initially Poe seemed to like an Army life:
in April of 1829 he applied to West Point
academy, looking forward to a promotion from
Sergeant to Lieutenant.
He entered the academy in the summer of 1830,
but by the following winter he was doing his
best to get kicked out.
A once talented cadet, Poe racked up 110 offenses
and 106 demerits in two terms.
He was court-martialed and tried at the beginning
of February 1831 for gross neglect of duty.
What was the cause for his rebellion?
Again, it all came from his relationship with
John Allan.
‘Pa’ had remarried, perhaps too quickly,
with Mrs Louisa Patterson, which Poe disliked.
Moreover, Edgar had discovered that John had
sired children out of wedlock.
The feud was embittered by a letter written
by Poe in which he claimed that John Allan
was seldom sober.
Edgar wanted to leave West Point to pursue
writing at this stage, but he needed John’s
authorisation for a voluntary discharge.
When John, now cold and distant, refused,
Edgar started his self-sabotaging campaign.
He succeeded, and was kicked out from the
academy … not before collecting donations
from 100 cadets to fund his next book of poems,
titled
“Poems”
In the summer of 1831, fate dealt another
blow to Edgar, as it claimed the life of his
brother Henry, yet another victim of tuberculosis.
Edgar’s writing career started to pick up
in the early 1830s, and his short story “Message
found in a bottle” won a $50 prize from
a Baltimore magazine in 1833.
The prize was very welcome, John had closed
the coffers.
Second wife Louisa did not approve of Edgar,
and plus the couple now had a biological son,
likely to inherit Allan’s wealth.
In 1834 John fell ill.
When Edgar heard the news, he tried to reunite
with him one last time.
They had not seen each other since West Point.
Edgar rushed to Richmond, overcame Louisa’s
resistance and finally came face to face with
the now terminal ‘Pa’.
Thomas Ellis, John’s business partner described
the tearful reunion:
“With what little strength was left in him,
John stood up …”
Did they hug?
Oh no:
“(John) raised his cane and threatened to
strike him if he came within his reach!”
It was the last time they ever met.
John Allan died on March 27, 1834 and his
will - it made no mention of Poe.
Bridal Ballad
In the second half of the 1830s Poe’s writing
career took off.
Rather: he was always employed, but he had
little fame and even less money.
Following his Ma’s death in 1829, Edgar
had developed a friendship with his cousin
Virginia Clemm, 13 years his junior.
Virginia was the daughter of Maria, who was
the sister of David Poe.
So she was a first-degree relative of Edgar’s
via his biological father, not his foster
family.
This relationship was initially an innocent
one, with Virginia acting as a go-between
for Edgar and a girl called Mary Devereaux,
whom he was trying to woo.
By 1835, when Poe was 26 and Virginia only
13, the friendship was developing into something
else.
Despite Virginia’s relatives’ best attempts,
on the 22nd of September 1835, Edgar and Virginia
married in secret, celebrating a public wedding
the following year.
Edgar even took in his aunt-and-mother-in-law
Maria Clemm.
He nicknamed her ‘Muddy’ for some reason
and apparently loved her as a mother, addressing
her as such in later poem.
Fun fact: after Poe’s death, Maria was completely
destitute, relying on charitable donations
– among the donors: Charles Dickens!
[Caption: Fun fact: a fun fact involving death
and poverty is not fun.]
Going back to Edgar and Virginia, a marriage
at such a young age would certainly not be
acceptable by today’s standards, and even
back then it was frowned upon.
But some authors claim that Edgar’s and
Virginia’s relationship may have been purely
platonic.
The theory is that after the death of both
his biological and foster mothers, Poe had
transferred his feelings of filial love to
Aunt Mary, and in turn, to Virginia.
You can draw a parallel with Poe’s work
at this stage, namely the short story ‘Morella’
of April 1835.
In this story, an unnamed narrator regards
“with a feeling of deep yet most singular
affection … my friend Morella”
The two marry and Morella grows obsessed with
death and issues of identity.
She dies in childbirth and the protagonist
decides to leave the baby girl unnamed for
ten years.
As she grows old, she is uncannily alike her
mother.
When the girl turns ten, the father agrees
to have her baptised.
When he chooses the name ‘Morella’, the
girl immediately dies, uttering ‘I am here!’.
The tale concludes:
“with my own hands I bore her to the tomb;
and I laughed with a long and bitter laugh
as I found no traces of the first in the channel
where I laid the second.
– Morella”
The tale features Poe’s recurring topics
of resurrection and identity beyond death.
And consider this: the narrator and Morella
are friends, before marrying, just like Edgar
and Virginia.
And then here is a transfer of identity from
mother to daughter, which opens the door to
more Freudian nightmares that I can handle
today.
Morella and the husband in the tale had a
happy marriage.
How was Edgar’s and Virginia’s?
Apparently, it was successful, despite lack
of money.
Virginia had a deep adoration towards Poe
and always kept his portrait under her pillow.
Edgar, on the other hand, had started flirting
with one Frances Sargent Osgood, but besides
exchanging letters there is no proof of a
relationship.
Frances was being unsuccessfully courted by
another author and journalist, Rufus W. Griswold,
keep an eye on him.
These letters were enough to enrage another
lady, Elizabeth Ellet, who had a crush on
Poe.
Her reaction caused a scandal, as she alleged
Poe and Frances had a physical affair.
She even spread rumours that Poe was
“subject to acts of lunacy.”
Virginia was unconcerned with Poe’s flirtations,
but this scandal affected deeply her frail
health.
The Man that Was Used Up
In the second half of the 1830s Poe went full
workaholic, moving frequently across East
Coast cities, looking for work in magazines.
He did not neglect his creative writing, though,
publishing his first and only novel, The Narrative
of Arthur Gordon Pym‍ in 1838.
In the following two years Poe published two
works: his seminal collection of ground-breaking
short stories ‘Tales of the Grotesque and
Arabesque’; and a treatise on shellfish,
‘The Conchologist’s First Book’, which
he co-authored.
One of the two sold out in just two months.
Guess which?
[Countdown on screen: 5 … 4 … 3…
2 … 1]
The shellfish.
It was the shellfish manual.
I am not going to comment on the taste of
American readers in the 1830s, but hey, this
was Poe’s only commercial success in his
lifetime.
But he never made a dime from royalties.
In 1841 Poe took a position as editor for
Graham’s Magazine, which he also used as
a platform for his own short stories.
Poe grew the circulation of the magazine from
5,000 to 37,000 subscribers.
Poe even convinced Charles Dickens to write
for the Graham!
But in May, Poe left the magazine, handing
over his duties to Rufus W. Griswold.
Remember him?
Poe wrote to a friend:
“My reason for resigning was disgust with
the namby-pamby character of the Magazine
… The salary, moreover, did not pay me for
the labour which I was forced to bestow”
By that time, Virginia had already fallen
ill to tuberculosis, some say as a consequence
of the Ellet scandal.
Her health worsened, but Poe did not stop
on his streak, he was finally going places.
In 1843 Poe’s tale ‘The Gold-Bug,” won
a $100 prize from a Philadelphia newspaper.
It was followed by a theatrical production
and a French translation, giving Poe some
deserved public attention.
He embarked on a tour of sold-out poetry lectures,
moved to New York, and was a sub-editor of
the Evening Mirror.
It was this paper that in January 1845 published
his most famous poem, “The Raven”.
It became an immediate, nation-wide hit.
What princely sum did Poe earn from this masterpiece?
Fifteen dollars.
$325 in today’s money.
In February Poe took control and ownership
of the Broadway Journal, but this did not
help him financially.
If anything, he accumulated even more debt,
and the Journal shut down in January next
year.
Things started to pick up thanks to royalties
from a publication about New York’s literary
scene, but life giveth and life taketh away:
Virginia’s condition worsened and by early
1846 she was bedridden.
She told a friend:
“I know I shall die soon … but I want
to be as happy as possible and make Edgar
happy.”
On the 30th of January 1847, Virginia Poe
died of tuberculosis in Fordham, New York.
On her deathbed, it is claimed that Virginia
blamed her death on the jealous Mrs. Ellet.
Poe’s love for Virginia was consuming, as
was his grief.
For almost two years he visited her grave
every day, keeping it fresh with flowers.
What future lay ahead of Edgar Allan Poe now
that her beloved Virginia was gone?
Let’s pause the man’s life for a while,
and let’s dig into his work.
Grotesque and Arabesque
Poe is remembered as master of Horror fiction,
and a father of the modern short story.
He composed his tales following two main rules:
each story should be short enough to be read
in one sitting; each word should contribute
to the overall effect of the story.
His published work came at the apex of the
Gothic and Romantic periods and had a great
influence in Europe, where he was idolised
by Charles Baudelaire and the movement of
the French “Poétes maudits”.
Beyond horror, his body of work encompasses
many other genres and in most cases, it is
not easy to define.
Take the short story “The Duc De L’Omelette”:
a French Aristocrat and gourmand dies of disgust
when a delicacy is improperly served to him.
He wakes up in a Hell and starts plotting
his way out.
He challenges Satan to a duel, but alas the
Prince of Hell does not fence.
The next best thing is a nice game of 21,
or Blackjack if you like.
Satan cannot refuse a game of cards: challenge
accepted.
The Duc, a skilled gambler, wins the game,
and his freedom.
In four pages Poe defines two characters,
sets up a conflict, establishes some devilish
lore along the way and crosses three genres:
comedy, horror and subtle satire of European
aristocracy.
Another cross-over of styles he achieved with
The Murders of the Rue Morgue.
There is some horror also here, with a killing
perpetrated by a monstrous assailant.
But, most of all, the tale is the first Detective
story.
Poe established the archetypes of the genre
with the following The Mystery of Marie Roget
and The Purloined Letter : a brilliant amateur
detective, Auguste Dupin, skilled at observation
and deduction; a friend who acts as a narrator;
a baffled Police force needing the amateur’s
help.
It’s Sherlock Holmes, more than 40 years
earlier.
The same collection “Tales by EA Poe”,
features The Gold Bug.
This adventure-slash-detective romp tells
the story of a narrator, his volatile friend
Legrand and a freed slave, Jupiter, who decipher
an encrypted message to find a pirate treasure.
The story is best remembered for Legrand’s
use of frequency analysis to crack the code
and for the depiction of Jupiter: to modern
ears, it is downright racist.
But assigning an important speaking role and
a great deal of action to a black character
in 1840s America was a rather progressive
move.
Bombast
Much of Poe’s writing career was dedicated
to reviews of other authors.
As a literary critic, Poe celebrated the works
of Washington Irving and Nathaniel Hawthorne,
among the classics of American literature.
But he was known and feared for how he destroyed
less skilled authors.
This earned him the nickname of
The Tomahawk Man
Tackling the poems of one William W. Lord,
Poe opines that
“the only remarkable things about Mr. Lord’s
compositions are their remarkable conceit,
ignorance, impudence, platitude, stupidity
and bombast.”
[Caption: Stupidity and Bombast]
“from any farther specimens of your stupidity,
good Lord deliver us!”
Ouch.
Novelists are no luckier.
Theodore S. Fay’s 1835 work ‘Norman Leslie’
was “unworthy of a school-boy.”
“There is not a single page of Norman Leslie
in which even a school-boy would fail to detect
at least two or three gross errors in Grammar,
and some two or three most egregious sins
against common-sense.”
The one who gets the full tomahawk treatment
is Morris Mattson’s novel ‘Paul Ulric’:
“The book before us is too purely imbecile
to merit an extended critique — but we shall
have no hesitation … in exposing fully before
the public eye its four hundred and forty-three
pages of utter folly, bombast, and inanity”
[Caption on screen: Bombast and Inanity]
Poe was not done yet:
“Such are the works which bring daily discredit
upon our national literature … (works) of
incongruous folly, plagiarism, immorality,
inanity, and bombast”
[Caption: Inanity and Bombast]
Poe also attacked fellow journalists, editors
and critics.
The editor of the Boston Miscellany, H.T.
Tuckermann, was an
“insufferably tedious and dull writer”
While critic Rufus W. Griswold was dismissed
as a
“toady, destined to sink into oblivion”
Griswold.
We’ll meet him again.
The Conqueror Worm
Poe’s reputation still today is one of a
heavy drinker, but actually it was only after
Virginia’s death that he gave in to alcohol.
And even then, he never drank in huge quantities.
The problem was that even a small quantity
of liquor could knock him out.
In November of 1848 Poe was courting poetess
Sarah Helen Whitman, no relation to Walt Whitman.
Mrs. Whitman was so concerned about his reputation
for drinking that asked for total abstinence
from alcohol as a condition for marriage.
Poe failed to meet the request and Sarah called
off the engagement.
In the summer of 1849 Poe was on a lecture
tour in Richmond when he met again his once
girlfriend Elmira, the one who had dumped
him for the businessman.
Elmira was now a widow and the two rekindled
their love affair.
In August, Elmira accepted Edgar’s proposal.
And Poe must have been dead serious about
it, as only two days later he joined the Sons
of Temperance, a sort of Alcoholic Anonymous
for the 19th century.
Everything was working out fine.
Then, the chain of events started, one that
would lead to Poe’s unresolved death.
On the 26th of September 1849, Poe visited
a physician friend called John Carter.
He was due to leave Richmond, Virginia to
go to Philadelphia to complete an editing
job.
Carter advised Poe to postpone his trip by
a few days, but he decided to leave any ways.
On the 27th of September 1849, Poe left Richmond
for Philadelphia.
For the following 6 days, he just vanished.
[Screen fades to black, a caption appears
on screen: Baltimore, Evening of the 3rd of
October, 1849]
A journalist called Joseph Walker, walking
outside the pub ‘Gunner’s Hall’ came
across a traumatised man, lying in the gutter.
The man was visibly ill, in a state of confusion
and dressed in worn-out, ill-fitting clothes.
The man introduced himself as Edgar Allan
Poe and asked for help.
Poe asked Walker to contact one Joseph Snodgrass,
a newspaper editor with a medical background.
Snodgrass took Poe to a hospital, where was
treated by Dr John Moran.
Moran noted down his patient’s symptoms:
fever, mania, revulsion to water, calling
for somebody called
‘Reynolds’
Moran also asked Poe where he had left his
possessions, but the writer could not remember.
On the 7th of October 1849, Edgar Allan Poe
died, aged 40.
The reported cause of death was phrenitis,
or swelling of the brain.
His mother-in-law, in hearing that Poe had
died, went to check on his cat, Catterina,
and found out that she had also died.
One of the early reported causes of Poe’s
death was alcohol abuse.
This unverified rumour was spread by Poe’s
obituary, more on this later.
Other possible causes include tuberculosis,
epilepsy, diabetes and even rabies – the
latter may be consistent with Catterina’s
death.
Author Matthew Pearl offered another explanation:
brain cancer.
This is consistent with the symptoms.
Plus, when Poe’s body was displaced to another
burial in 1875, the coffin broke and witnesses
noticed a small clump rolling inside Poe’s
skull.
This could have been a calcified tumour.
Other theories involve violent crime: Poe
may have been assaulted, beaten up by ruffians,
as claimed in 1867 by biographer E. Oakes
Smith.
But Poe’s body did not display any sign
of external violence.
Another crime theory involves ‘cooping’.
This was a common type of electoral fraud
at the time.
Gangs of thugs would abduct and ‘coop up’
citizens from the streets and force them into
a disguise so they could vote several times
for the same candidate.
The victims were threatened with violence
or rewarded with alcohol.
Intriguing theory, mentioned for the first
time in the early 1870s.
Points in favour:
Baltimore at that time was in the middle of
a local election
Gunner’s hall was a polling station
Poe was wearing somebody else’s clothes
Baltimore’s newspaper The Republican and
Argus published warnings against cooping on
the 1st and 3rd of October.
Now, we are not Dupins, but we have done some
extra sleuthing of our own.
We searched the enigmatic name ‘Reynolds’
in local Maryland newspapers and we found
that in September there were two people called
Reynold acting as District Delegates in Elkton,
just outside Baltimore.
Could they be involved in the local Baltimore
elections?
Was this a name that Poe heard, or read, while
being cooped?
We also spoke with an oncology surgeon, formerly
at one of London’s biggest cancer centres,
whom we will call “Dr M”.
Dr M confirmed that tumoural masses can calcify
even when the surrounding healthy tissue decomposes.
He offered an additional explanation for the
clump rolling inside Poe’s skull: a head
trauma.
Not only it can cause death, but it can also
cause a small bone between the cheekbone and
the jaw to fracture and detach, free to rattle
inside the skull.
A blunt trauma at the back of the head would
not leave visible injuries – and Poe’s
body did not display any sign of violence.
There are many more theories, so I am going
to stop there.
Gun to the head, I would go with cooping plus
the blunt trauma.
Why don’t you tell us your theory in the
comments?
Nevermore
On the 9th of October 1849 an obituary of
Poe’s appeared on the New York Tribune,
signed “Ludwig”.
We don’t know if Poe’s death was an assassination,
but certainly this article was character assassination.
While praising Poe’s work, ‘Ludwig’
wrote that few will be grieved by his death,
that the writer had little to no friends and
led a dissolute and dissipate life.
Ludwig would publish yet more articles praising
Poe the author while destroying Poe the man,
exaggerating or inventing embarrassing details.
These articles were now signed with his real
name:
Rufus W. Griswold.
The irony is that Griswold was Poe’s executor,
meaning he had the rights to edit and publish
his works for a nice profit, all the while
cementing the image of the dissolute and lunatic
alcoholic still surviving today.
I hope you have learned something new about
Edgar Allan Poe today, please spread the word.
We had to skip tons of stuff but if you want
to dig deeper check out the website of the
Edgar Allan Poe Society of Baltimore, www.eapoe.org,
it’s a real mine of free material, including
his full works.
And if we hear somebody repeating one of Griswold’s
lies … well, like Poe’s Raven, let’s
just say
“Nevermore!”